do you think I think we're about ready
to get started thank you for coming to
the Chicago Public Library tonight for
this special event with David Starkey we
are very pleased to have you and the
author here tonight we're also pleased
to have Barbara's bookstore here selling
books for tonight's event and if you
haven't already purchased your books you
can do so right outside of the room
after the event after mr. Starkey's
presentation he will be signing books
right up here I'd like to tell you a
little bit about the book and mr.
Starkey before we begin although his
presentation I'm sure you'll find
fascinating I'm enjoying the book very
much and I highly recommend it you
probably know David Starkey as one of
Britain's more foremost authorities on
English monarchy and the Tudor history
his new book Elizabeth the struggle for
the throne exemplifies his authority in
these subject matters Elizabeth the
first is often thought of as England's
greatest queen and much has been written
about her however it is mr. Starkey's
focus on Elizabeth's extraordinary and
very dramatic formative years before she
was Queen that sheds new light on the
circumstances that motivated this young
woman to such a successful reign David
Starkey has taught and written
extensively on a broad spectrum of
British culture social and political
history his books include rivals and
power the reign of Henry the eighth
personalities and politics and the
English court from the Wars of the Roses
to the Civil War he is also written and
presented to major television series
this land of England and Henry the
eighth and is planning to more royal
biographies as a commentator on the
British monarchy mr. Starkey has
appeared on and hosted numerous
television and radio programs and has
been profiled in a number of journals in
newspapers he has taught at the London
School of Economics and Dartmouth
College and has been a fellow at
fitzwilliam college in Cambridge it is
my pleasure to introduce David Starkey
lady would those who haven't got a seat
like to come and seat themselves that
makes it easier doesn't it
splendid ladies and gentlemen it's a
very great pleasure to be here this
evening talking about Elizabeth and
talking about this book in the kind of
building which I think she could have
only envied as a palace and it is it
convinces me that America and Stalin's
Russia more in common than they would
like to admit it is truly truly
magnificent I've had a bit of my opening
really taken from me which is why on
earth write another book on Elizabeth
the answer in a sense is here in the
cover of this book we all know don't we
or we all think we know what Elizabeth
looked like now in Britain what I'm
going to say now is a very good joke
here it may be entirely incomprehensible
it may be also seen as being in bad
taste but never mind I will try it
the Elizabeth the Gloriana figure looks
doesn't she exactly like so Roy strong
in drag I mean you get you get the
extraordinary ginger wig the piled up
hair the grotesque dresses
the face whited out in fact in white
lead with with disastrous consequences
the carmine lips the bizarrely long
hands with those amazing clusters of
rings and symbol after symbol after
symbol eyes icons little bits and pieces
of Merman extra-extraordinary sibs
whatever look at this this is Elizabeth
aged 13 this is Elizabeth in what I
think is one of the 16th centuries most
utterly beautiful portraits and his a
staggeringly lovely portrait it's her
last present to her father done probably
in January 1547 and it shows Elizabeth
as this intense young surprisingly
attractive girl
in English one we would say there's a
little bit of a touch of Essex about her
a slight slight touch of New Jersey but
but nevertheless it is a strikingly
straightforward image unmade up and this
extraordinary face which is essentially
her father's face that's to say the
auburn hair the English royal house has
Alban hair the medieval royal houses
urban hair and this extraordinary pale
ivory skin the very long nose and the
little tiny sort of rosebud and mouth
which of course a particularly grotesque
when Henry VIII gets old and fat and
then the only things that really mark
her out as her mother's child the very
very dark black eyes
it's an extraordinary picture and
holding here and on the spine a book
another great book on a lectern open in
front of her the Ray model of the
Protestant learning princess and then
behind her which you can just vaguely
see the aubergine drapes of her bed
something that we'll talk about quite a
lot she's reading in her bedchamber now
the picture we can respond to instantly
but when I saw that picture in the Royal
Collection and again as well as was
being explained I have studied the Tudor
period ever since I was an undergraduate
student more years ago than I care to
remember the thing that struck me was I
didn't know who it was I did not read up
would you I did not recognize it as
Elizabeth so I had from that point
onwards the ambition to try to connect
this Elizabeth - Elizabeth that we
always know how on earth does this girl
become that bizarre woman what is it and
she is very bizarre I mean it is I mean
there's the Elizabeth of the last 15
years it's one of the most extraordinary
confection preachers ever to have ruled
I mean she looks like a Cleopatra or
dare I say it perhaps Elizabeth Taylor
as Cleopatra which is even stranger even
stream even stranger than the real thing
there's even the touch of the it is
beylin now which is stranger than all of
them but anyway isn't it my interest was
how that became that that's the first
starting point of this biography the
second is a more general point about
royal lives and the peculiar difficulty
of royal biographies most of us actually
know when were born we have a single
birthday
and if we're important enough to have a
biography our life is told as a
continuous story from that point but if
your royal you have two birthdays you
have the day when you're born and the
day when you accede to the throne and
nearly all royal lives begin when they
come to the throne they eliminate the
youth or just gloss it over there's a
very fine life for example of Henry the
eighth's Henry the eighth Elizabeth's
father by jacks carries brick I think it
devotes eight pages to the period before
Henry comes to the throne now Henry is
17 years and 10 months when he comes to
the throne as you were hearing I spent
much of my life teaching school if I had
eliminated the first 17 years and 10
months of those boys and girls that I've
been teaching they would have still been
in diapers now we know of course
students quite often behave as though
they were in diapers
nevertheless the whole of their
prehistory would have been eliminated
you don't have to be a Jesuit and
believe that the first seven years can't
you don't or all that matter
you don't have to be afraid you to
realize that youthful childhood
experience is the sensual experience in
making all of us what we are isn't it
isn't it I mean it seems so self-evident
but why isn't biography written like
this why is it regarded as being
something rather unusual a new and very
important book has recently been
published in Britain on on Margaret
Thatcher which does exactly the same
thing it tries to look at her youth the
prob
of course is as Margaret Thatcher only
became royal rather than being born
royal the the the early life isn't very
well documented the thing that's
important about young royal lives is
that they're very often exceedingly
well-documented as I shall be trying to
show you
Elizabeth's life is so the portrait the
idea of the importance of early years
have been above all the sheer
peculiarity of Elizabeth's own
experience again briefly alluded to she
is much older than her father when she
comes to the throne she's 25 now let me
just quickly give you an idea of those
25 years in terms of a roller coaster
many young royal lives are of course not
worth spending much time on because
they're so prosaic they're a cross
between a silver teaspoon in the mouth
and a golden high road to the throne and
you know being a sort of agreeable
waster along the way and there's the
sort of treatment that Shakespeare gives
to his imaginary Henry v Elizabeth's
life is completely utterly fundamentally
different so let's do it in terms of
reviewing the peaks and the troughs of
the rollercoaster
just to get an idea of the shape right
and then what I will do in the second
half of my talk I will actually
highlight what I think are the crucial
questions in terms of both the novelty
of the approach of the book particular
types of evidence if you like the
psychology of the whole thing but I'll
begin by giving you a rough sense of the
chronology and one of the things that I
want to emphasize and we're about this
book it is totally chronological there
is only one chapter on her education
that pulls out from chronology and what
I learned in writing this was that it's
possible to write something which is
absolutely rigorously narrative whilst
at the same time going into very great
detail on all kinds of particular events
problems of religion how the court
organizes itself all this kind of thing
but the key is to keep a narrative this
is above all a story and it seems to me
to be the only proper way to
do a biography right then the
roller-coaster the peaks and the troughs
Elizabeth is born in September 15:33 the
second child of Henry the eighth's
and of course the first child of his
marriage his second marriage with Anne
Boleyn that being extraordinary and
momentous and his first marriage his
marriage to Katharine of Aragon which
produced a single daughter Mary
Elizabeth's half-sister is broken by an
extraordinary series of events there is
no tribe there is no son Henry regards
himself therefore as childless and he
also falls out of love with Catherine of
Aragon there's no doubt whatever that
all Henry's marriage is in one way or
another our love marriages Henry is very
unusual amongst monarchs in that he
regards marriage as we do about being
happy that's why he divorces so often
right true isn't it I mean come on let's
face it the the best that any sensible
person looks for in marriage is to be
content but that leave that aside
Henry had fallen out of love with
Catherine of Aragon who beginning pretty
and brunette and of course seven years
older than Henry had under the terrible
the strain of terrible and repeated
miscarriages got dumpy and fat and
flabby and taken badly to religion and
Henry had obviously got very bored with
her and he falls in love instead with
Anne Boleyn Elizabeth's mother but of
course it's this is I'm emphasizing the
soap opera side and the important thing
is to begin with the personal relations
the issues of religion the issues of
relations with Rome all the rest would
only come afterwards I it's really it's
really very important we realize this
the personal becomes the political but
if it hadn't have been for the personal
if it hadn't been for the personal
tensions the political and religious
questions would never have happened
so Elizabeth is the child of this
extraordinary momentous divorce and
remarriage the tears England away from
Rome that tears apart the English royal
family because interestingly most of the
royal fan
side with Catherine of Aragon they take
the side of the woman something that
that's that so often happens in these
kind of circumstances and therefore
tears apart Henry's own life and
Elizabeth is the daughter of this
extraordinary circumstance she is the
symbol of the new the Reformation just
as much as Mary her half-sister is the
symbol of the old more important still
from the point of view of this biography
Elizabeth is the first woman to be
recognized at the moment of birth as
heir to the English throne
she's proclaimed princess and Princess
doesn't just mean any old royal child
and you know female royal child of
course as we use it now prince or
princess is used only absolutely only
for the heir to the throne so when she's
proclaimed princess she's recognized as
heir to the throne from the moment of
birth
remember what underlies the whole of
this extraordinary story of Henry the
eighth's and his marriages is no woman
at yet sat on the throne of England and
it was probably illegal
the assumption is from the later Middle
Ages that England operates a form of
salic law that's to say female
succession is excluded and and it is
only the the bizarre events of Henry's
reign and his decisions about the
succession that we'll review in a second
that reverses that so Elizabeth is born
at this extraordinary peak right and yet
within three years she hits the lowest
conceivable trough in 1536 in May 1536
Henry divorces and beheads her execute
her and with that awful combination of
smugness and self-righteousness which
characterizes the older Henry in his the
execution warrant for Anne he
congratulates himself on not having
inflicted the full penalties of the lon
and given her a gentle death the full
penalties for treason for a woman were
burning alive horrible death and his
terrifying fight instead Anne is
executed with the sword she's beheaded
with the sword
normally exit
in England in those days involved
execution with the heading acts which
involves your lying prone on the
scaffold you don't kneel you lie prone
on the scaffold your head is on on a
block with a little sort of Nick
therefore your chin and the head is
hacked off it can take up to four or
five strokes to get the thing off
it is not pretty the French on the other
hand are observed superior dexterity in
executions as in cooking you know they
do it they do it with style and French
executions are done with a two-handed
heading sword and you don't you don't
you don't go prone you kneel and I think
it must be the origin of the expression
chin up and you sneak it off so quit
quite says you have this sword and and
the Turks use use the same method of
same method of doing it and you get this
huge heavy sword swinging faster and
faster and faster and then you ask and
on the eve eve of her execution and the
famous remark I have a little neck and
indeed it came off with a single stroke
but although Henry observed a certain
degree of tenderness in the method of
execution there was none in the
destruction of Anne she is destroyed on
charges of adultery of witchcraft and of
incest and it's a deliberate and
complete destruction of a woman's
character my late medieval Latin is not
too bad but I freely admit that I did
not know the Latin for a French kiss
until I read the indictment and it goes
on extensively about tongues behind
teeth and you know this is with her
brother George Boleyn Lord Rochford and
it's utterly false it's completely phony
the whole thing is a confection where
these sexual relations is supposed to
have taken place the people weren't it's
it's a fiction but it's a very very
clever fiction so as you can imagine
most people assume that this is the axis
event in Elizabeth's life I don't think
it is
I hate to undercut it all after that
magnificent build-up - it was good
wasn't it but anyway I think I think we
must we must take a deep breath but I'll
just flag up that I don't actually think
but it's the key let's move forward and
look from the trough at how quickly she
pulls out of it within three years
Elizabeth is already being seen as so
desirable I mean remember she's a royal
bastard but she's still royal a
household is already being seen as so
desirable that important noble ladies
are queuing up to get their daughters
into it right that's only three years
after her mother's execution within
another four years
that's in 1543 she is restored to the
succession it's extraordinary
Henry the eighth keeps both his
daughters bastard he keeps them
illegitimate but he puts them back in
the succession talk about having your
cake and eating it but you know it is
quite bizarre there formally proclaimed
heirs to the throne by both Henry's will
and more importantly by Act of
Parliament you paint a picture to
represent the fact but you don't
legitimate them so he's not forced to
admit that he'd been wrong to divorce
the wives but the children still placed
in the succession it's the only time in
English history that bastards have ever
actually been formally placed placed in
the succession so Elizabeth then soars
right up Henry treats in exactly the
same way in his will as he does hire her
half-sister Mary
both of them are left this enormous
fortune about which we will talk in his
will right right you see what I mean
there's extraordinary descent and
bouncing right up again and however
within a few months of the accession of
her little half-brother the son of the
woman who'd replaced her mother Jane
Seymour displaces Anne Boleyn and with
the six becomes king after Henry's death
within a few months of his accession to
the throne
Elizabeth crashes right down again
because what happens is she goes to live
with her stepmother Katherine Parr
Henry's last wife and the man that
Katherine Parr a quickly remarries
Thomas Seymour one of the uncle's of the
new King Thomas Seymour is probably best
described as the Mel Gibson of the early
to court he is the sort of hunk and
every woman goes for him and catherine
parr the supposedly pious and protestant
Catherine pass rules I mean she just
loses her head completely she throws
over decency she marries him within
three months of Henry's death which his
regard as a complete outrage you know
fervor for for the Queen Dowager to do
that and Elizabeth goes off to live with
them and there she's subject to
something well I called it child abuse
and the English some of the English
press got a bit cross with me but let me
describe some of the things that
happened and one of the questions who
should be having running through your
brains is how on earth does he know
right elizabeth is pinioned with our
arms behind her back by catherine parr
whilst Thomas Seymour cuts her dress off
with a knife now how do you think that
would play in the local district court
here I mean how long before they were
both inside right on other occasions
Seymour comes into the service bedroom
of which he's procured the key while
she's still in bed and the documents say
bare-legged now that doesn't sound too
bad except remembered in the 16th
century gentleman did not wear boxer
shorts
so he's wearing only a shirt and a
nightgown he then proceeds to climb into
bed with her to tickle her to pull up
her night skirt sort of night dresser
shift slap her on the back side as it as
it says this is why the Victorians
couldn't publish any of these documents
you understand they got they got very
worried about all this kind of thing it
chases her round the bedpost hides
behind the curtains quite extraordinary
even more extraordinary Lizabeth
reaction she seems to have enjoyed it
I have to said she wants to marry him
that she says this quite explicitly
there is no doubt about it at all
on the other hand it ruins her or it
comes within a whisker of ruining her
because all this becomes public
knowledge Seymour is put on trial partly
for this partly also for having plotted
to take over from his elder brother
Edward Seymour Duke of Somerset the Lord
Protector that's equivalent of Regent
for the little boy King and he is
executed and all the sordid details of
the goings on between him and Elizabeth
are made semi public and Elizabeth's
reputation is in tatters she's brought
to London everybody's laughing saying
you know she's pregnant by him
extraordinary and yet her luck holds
within what is it four months of the
culmination of this affair Edward
Seymour the elder brother who's brought
down his younger brother Falls the
protector falls at the end of 1549
because even in Tudor England procuring
the execution of your brother was
regarded as being rather bad form so he
falls and suddenly Elizabeth finds
herself as being flavor of the month
with the new regime which happens to be
headed up by John Dudley that family
with whom she's going to be so closely
involved from that point onwards though
if she bounces right back she's in high
favor with her brother she's given
possession of the vast estates that
she'd been left by her father and she
rides through triumphantly the end of
Edwards reign when there's a very
serious attempt at all in the succession
which would have removed both Elizabeth
and Mary from the succession she rides
through the Jane Grey affair and instead
she enters London at Mary's right hand
when Mary seizes the throne in an armed
coup in 1553
it's the same at the coronation she's
second only to the Queen isn't it
delicious in the coronation procession
she rise along with that wonderful old
survivor and of Cleves who's still
around you know and still actually being
treated as royal but within three months
of that when Mary sort of brought to the
throne with acclamation there is a huge
popular revolt the wire rebellion
because meantime Mary's announced a
determination to marry
for Spain and the English are a
xenophobic then as they thought of
English football lout is now and they're
behaving much the same kind of fashion
and as this great revolt in which
Elizabeth is involved up to the neck and
the neck comes very near sharing the
same fate as her mother's she's
imprisoned in the tower as a traitor
she's taken into the tower past the
great menagerie where the Royal Lions
are kept and from that moment on was
Elizabeth constantly hearts back to
being like Daniel in the lion's den she
uses the biblical text she's taken
further into the inner ward of the tower
those of you have ever visited the tower
you'll know you're actually following
the route that you go into the tower now
and then you go under the bloody tower
turning up towards the scaffold where
the scaffold is and Elizabeth is
deliberately taken past that asks is it
for me it's the scaffold on which Jane
Grey had just been executed and then
she's taken into the inner ward of the
tower not imprisoned in a dungeon as the
legend says but in the rooms where her
mother have been imprisoned the night
before her death its psychological
torture brilliantly handled but she
survives she suffers terrible migraine
she gets sort of psychosomatic swellings
all this kind of thing but she survives
and she survives the period the twelve
months of house arrest that follows and
the immense sustained pressure that's
brought to bear on her for the rest of
Mary's reign to marry abroad get out of
England go anywhere but just get herself
out of the way and she survives and
towards the end of Mary's reign she
thinks she's going to have to fight for
the throne so she begins to build up an
army which I'm quite sure she would have
led herself at Tilbury much later on of
course she sort of leads the troops
wearing a kind of Madonna breastplate
and that this would have been for real
there's no doubt about it and the book
again documents some of the plans which
are being made actually
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu muster troops and she
becomes queen so that gives you an idea
of why I think this is important that
absolutely extraordinary pattern of
experience because the key fact to
emerge from this from Elizabeth's
biography is on
most monitors she actually has
experience of being on the receiving end
power as well as on the giving end of
power and I think that's crucial and if
you look for example in the extreme use
of royal power the power of life and
death Henry the eighth for one set of
reasons and Mary for another set of
reasons
positively enjoy signing death warrants
Mary does it conscientiously because she
say
remember when she burns heretics she
doesn't think that she's doing something
wrong
the most extraordinary thing we have to
understand is she's absolutely sure
she's doing something right which is
precisely what's that Weis and Thomas
Moore burned heretics they believed so
powerfully that anybody who disbelieved
was willfully evil and had to be rooted
out less great and evil was done Henry
behaves in the same fashion for rather
different reasons I'm also because of
his religious beliefs but a but above
all because of this pure absolute
exercise of royal authority after the
Reformation Henry actually looks again
at the coronation oath and there's this
very remarkable Klaus still sworn in the
coronation oath in which the monarch
says I promise to do justice in mercy
and in truth and in his revision of the
coronation I was Henry's pen goes to the
words in mercy and I promise to do
justice in truth that's what he promises
now Elizabeth is completely different
when she signs a death warrant she
agonizes in the case of the Duke of
Norfolk she organizes for two months and
we have these wonderful notes written
from her to Lord Burleigh her chief
minister saying I can't sleep my maids
don't know what to do with me advise me
I cannot sign this warrant in the case
of Mary she hesitates for two decades
and it seems to me that this she does it
finally she know she has to but this
this awareness of the reality of what
you're doing to somebody this hesitation
I find profoundly attractive there's a
sort of humanity which is something that
you find very rarely
sixteenth-century monix so that's the
structure no let's just pick out what i
regard is one or two of the absolute
central points in my account and and
where there are novelties and so on the
first obviously is in the question of
the relationship between the father and
the mother and the daughter I've
emphasized that I don't actually think
that this is the key moment very simply
I don't think it because Elizabeth
didn't think it
Elizabeth mentions her mother twice in
her entire life and they are entirely
neutral observations now of course if
you're a four again you say that's just
because the trom is too deep buried I'm
awfully sorry I don't wear that sort of
thing
I mean Freud I regard as a higher
fiction and what if what is much more
what is much I said all psychologists
nowadays but and what is not what is
much more interesting is Elizabeth
attitude to her father her father's name
is constantly on her lips at the age of
six she's actually described by a
courtier who was presented her with a
gift in the King's name patronized her
and been quelled by this little
six-year-old girl drawing herself up and
commanding him using the Royal we in our
name you know to give our greetings to
our royal father and to ask that mother
and then just to make sure he got the
point putting it in Latin and I rather
suspect in Greek as well you know at six
at which point the Royal servant thinks
oh my god I've made the most awful
blunder and this wonderful phrase she is
in truth her father's daughter which is
the thing that she pins herself to from
this moment onwards and when the Daily
Mail in London said the men in London
serialized this book a sort of
mid-market tabloid but it does pay very
well but never mind and it used as one
of its headlines daddy's girl
sorry it's puke making but it gets it
really really it really does get the
idea right now how could she do this now
this is the question right the first
thing to remember is we get the idea of
the Tudors family structure completely
wrong we implicitly sort of make them
bow
we think of the king and the queen
somehow living in a duplex you know
little Elizabeth is in the crib at the
foot of the bed she starts crying Henry
rolls over says God and you deal with it
it's your problem not like that the king
and the Queen have separate apartments
Henry's apartments at Hampton Court
cover about one and a half acres the
rooms cover about one and a half acres
the rooms only meet actually at the
Royal bedchambers the king and queen do
not spend the day with each other six
o'clock each night the King's most
important body servant the equivalent of
the chief of staff goes along the knocks
on the door and there's a response from
within and he then says how does the
Queen the King requires to know how doth
the Queen I've never understood whether
this is code for do you want it tonight
dearie or not you know that's the sort
of pattern and Elizabeth's has got to be
seen within this kind of extraordinary
structure the moment she is born she's
taken to be baptized it's a ceremony of
between five and six hundred people at
which neither of her parents are present
she's then removed and given into the
hands of a wet nurse she's not suckled
by her mother the wet nurse has become
major figures Henry the eighth's wet
nurse turns up at his coronation in a
sort of special box and you know you can
imagine her sitting there who hasn't
Henri done well sort of a eunuch is the
same with Elizabeth she's got a
household of a hundred and fifty
servants including four magnificently
named rockers they do not wear sort of
black leather studs and ride Harley
Davidsons but their job is to rock the
cradle in six hour shifts she's got two
cradles and every day cradle made out of
simple things like silver and sable and
a bit like my hotel bedroom and then and
then and then she's got a cradle of
estate in her case it's designed by
Holbein it's covered in beaten gold it's
got a quilt made out of iron and cloth
of gold it's got a cloth of gold canopy
it stands on a platform covered in
turkey carpets and purple velvet
cushions it is a baby throne and that's
you did you see what I mean this is the
world you've deceived them it and she's
20 miles away from London what goes on
in London the awful fate of her mother
slowly filters through into this world
and her attachment is to the people who
bring her up not primarily to her
parents she actually says this in her
letters and also she's got another
example which is the example of Mary
Mary does genuinely what people think
Elizabeth did she attaches herself to
her mother and her mother's memory with
the--and to her mother's religion and to
her mother's country spain with fatal
consequences much good it did her
because of course all the past with her
father and I think Elizabeth is a clever
little girl her earliest memories
because the children are brought up
together is of Mary bawling her eyes out
because she wouldn't do what her father
told her to thank you Lisbeth things
well you know oh well there's probably
an easier way and and she had this
hugely develop political sense from an
early point so I think we need to think
of that relationship there now I've
highlighted in this account one of the
most I think original features of the
book which is my use of the
documentation relating to etiquette and
to the actual structures of households
and everyday life their lives on the one
hand are extraordinary familiar to us on
the other hand they're completely alien
and different and I've tried to get us
into that world the next thing that's
important and I think will already be
becoming clear is I do radically revised
my view or rather our view of the role
of women in the sixteenth century I
think this has been badly got wrong we
tend to think of women in the 16th
century like early editions of mid
Victorian ladies all stays smelling
salts and you know avoidance of public
life it ain't true
it simply is not true at the age of 16
after the conclusion of the seymour
affair elizabeth finds herself mistress
of the great fortune that she's left by
her father that involves roughly owning
for english couches right she has 20
houses on one occasion when she's
accused of mustering troops
one of them a place called Donington
castle the way she handles it's very
simple would you mind spelling that D o
Darlington do I have a house called
Donington you know complete Bluff of
course but she's 20 houses
she has 250 servants regularly she is in
sole charge of this household the men
dance offenders upon her take her orders
when she comes to London she rides with
an escort sometimes of up to two
thousand armed men wearing livery and
girl chains and a townhouse in London is
Somerset House which is bigger more
modern and more elegant than the King's
own palace
right she's a great princess and we must
see her a whole roll under Edward and
Mary has got to be seen in this light
not as a unit not the sort of standard
sort of you know and Antonia Fraser has
vision of poor wee women a mother is not
like that it really is it's radically
different and then the final thing that
I'd like to touch on now because time
begins to run short
the final thing I'd like to touch on is
the relationship between her and her
sister there are sections of this book
in which the book becomes almost two
parallel lives of Elizabeth and of Mary
and I got the idea of this from a very
remarkable they're call that I let see
only their the accounts of England
written at the end of their term by the
Venetian ambassadors and the Venetian
ambassador leaving England towards the
end of Mary's reign writes this
wonderful pair of parallel written
portraits of Elizabeth and Mary and it
struck me as being so useful that I
actually made made made this a core
element of the book and I think it
represents a fairly fundamental revision
of how the politics of Mary's reign
operate as well but I want just to
highlight one thing Elizabeth as I've
emphasized sees her father as the model
of good government she sees her sister
on the other hand as the model of bad
government and it's something you should
all be worried about because the issue
that is at stake is the relationship
between religion and politics and which
should come first
America has no king but Jesus I believe
is the phrase now let me marry believer
marry believe that except that she was
queen but it was her duty fundamentally
to serve her God would you like to know
how she decided to get married get
married to Philip of Spain the most
important decision any monarch could
take she explicitly refused advice from
both parliament and her counsel instead
at the moment of decision there are only
three people present a favorite lady in
waiting
the Spanish ambassador herself and it
took place in a chapel in her most
secret private oratory on the altar was
the reserved sacrament if you are a
Catholic the body and the blood of
Christ the three of them fling
themselves on their knees and sing the
great Latin Pentecostal him the hymn
that invokes the flames of fire the
direct inspiration of the Holy Ghost
come Holy Ghost God descending vainly
clear tore spitty to half way through
this is the Spanish ambassador writing
merry rises as one possessed it's a
religious act and says even as God had
chosen a husband and then she goes
through all the biblical women you know
Elizabeth as Susannah Rebecca the whole
lot of them and the Virgin Mary because
Mary is the first woman to be called the
Virgin Queen as you would expect from
Mary even as he'd chosen a husband for
all of these culminating of the Virgin
so he'd chosen her husband for her and
his name was Philip and those whom God
hath joined let no man put asunder
that's how you decide to get married
would you like to know how she decided
she was pregnant she did not go to
either the gynecologist or the drugstore
right instead it happens when she is
receiving the papal legate Cardinal pool
as England is about to be received back
into the arms of Rome the legate comes
up the great gallery of Whitehall palace
the queen is at dinner she breaks
precedent by coming down the gallery to
meet him he should have gone to meet her
as the two meet Cardinal pool
how does he greet her take the tip of
the Virgin Mary
guess the words of the denunciation Ave
Maria plain Agora TIA hail Mary full of
grace thou that art highly favored
amongst women and how did the virgin
respond the bay but stirred in her womb
and what does Mary do the babes stirred
in her womb do you know how long the
pregnancy lasted 12 months with at least
two deliveries it was complete fiction
it's almost certainly as it's a false
pregnancy partly hysterical it's partly
probably the result of a cancer of the
pituitary gland and awful Elizabeth is
with her she sees the humiliation she
sees the whole because you know the
rumors begin to go round that the
Queen's been delivered of a monkey the
whole reign just cut which has been very
successful to that point just collapses
easy then II wonder ladies and gentlemen
that Elizabeth takes a radically
different view of how politics and
religion relate to each other is it any
wonder that she regards Mary as a
disaster is it any wonder that she
begins her inauguration just had an
inauguration and incidentally she didn't
ride in a bulletproof limo and as she
and she was in a litter exposed to the
people and talk to them directly is it
any wonder she begins her reign by
promising not to make Mary's mistakes
ladies and gentlemen unless we
understand this first 25 years of
Elizabeth we understand nothing
questions
the gentleman back there yes there are I
mean what I think is very striking about
Elizabeth is that like Princess Diana
she's a natural star and I have not to
be very impressed by Diana but an awful
lot of people were because she just has
the ability to hold eyes to involve
people to move people like her father
him as the 8th have the same quality
mary did not Elizabeth has it in spades
Elizabeth also like diana is vividly
aware of popularity she spends our whole
time cultivating popularity in just the
same way that diana did is is
calculating it's as clever in diana is
not clever and intellectual in the way
that elizabeth was was brilliant in
tonight but she had the same kind of
flair the same kind of ability at public
performance and the descriptions of
Elizabeth's inaugural procession
you know Bush would have eaten his eyes
out I mean if he could his heart out if
he could have done anything like so good
because she she says repeatedly I will
never lose popularity she's a sensitive
to popularity as any modern politician
so yes there are some very striking
resemblances and of course she's also
plays that as Diana did the role of the
oppressed outsider with brilliant
brilliant effect brilliant effect
given all the trouble and Elizabeth got
involved with with Thomas Seymour why
did he get into it say a similar
situation with the Earl of Eisner Robert
Dudley will oh well as I've already
pointed out I'm afraid she seems rather
to have enjoyed the Seymour thing so if
she enjoyed it presumably she wanted
more of it I mean I think the thing we
have to understand with Elizabeth she
does not announce she's going to be the
Virgin Queen Elizabeth has perfect he's
a perfectly ordinary gynecologic
complete woman
with passions with the passions of a
woman and you know the extraordinary
story of her life is the more remarkable
if we do recognize that fact I also
think there's something else I'm very
pleased you brought it up because in in
in trying to shape shape shape shape my
talk I did omit one point it seems to me
that the Seymour affair is the key
affair in establishing Elizabeth's
relations with men not the business of
her father because if you actually look
at all the men that Elizabeth finds
attractive they all look like Thomas
Seymour they're the same bill same looks
there are sort of English football
players you know and and there's a
single exception to this and of course
he's French the the the Duke of an old
song but it's as though this sort of
sets a pattern for Elizabeth in her
relations with men and also of course in
the in the way which they all finally
turned out to be abortive but the only
way we can understand the questions of
marriages I think is not the dualism
birth absolutely decides not to marry
though she has doubts about it
because remember my description of that
extraordinary estate that she has it was
a little bit like Cinderella
Cinderella's coach you may remember
disappeared when midnight chimed
Elizabeth's estate disappeared with the
chime of a wedding bell because it was
only there to tide her over to the
moment that she got married so these are
the sort of pictures that we need to put
in but she got entangled with Dudley
because she found him attractive she
couldn't keep her hands off him I mean
there are descriptions you know which I
think I believe they are passionately in
love and you know what was found under
her pillow
and she when she died oh it's so sick
making I mean really Hollywood couldn't
do it better
there is Dudley's last letter to her
tear-stained with a pin through it with
Anya Lizabeth handwritten at the bottom
his last letter you know she's human
underneath all that nonsense it is
literally there it is actually still
preserved with her hand at the bottom
she kept it you know I think in her
bosom and then puts it under the pillow
which one Cate Blanchett Cate Blanchett
yeah yeah yeah yes I did I mean it's all
for history but that doesn't but but
that doesn't matter
that doesn't matter shake as much of
Shakespeare's bad history it's a good
movie and Cate Blanchett is a very
moving an impressive version of
Elizabeth it's preposterous history
not much she's a redhead and not much I
mean the structure of her face is
different I mean that's what it is about
look like Kate but it doesn't have that
length of face all those cheekbones
if you actually want to know something
who actually conveyed the appearance of
Elizabeth much more effectively than
cate blanchett it was the woman who
played Elizabeth in my TV series which
goes with this book which I hope will be
coming to the US fairly soon and she was
brilliant and she's not an actress of
Cate Blanchett's quality in terms of
speech but in terms of appearance and
how she conducted herself as an image
she sent out she was wonderful I think
you've had your share this he drew quite
a lot of other people you you may have a
supplemental ad judgement that movie
when he's speaking of the character in
the movie uh I think it's been Jeffrey
somebody plays the character Wolf's in
Hammond yeah is he as portrayed in the
movie you know he seemed to be a very
integral part of her you know protection
and security yes there is no doubt that
what I think we've got again to
understand the problem with the movie is
that it telescopes time it's something
that you regularly have to do when
you're making a movie because you've
only got two and a half hours to do it
in right and
and what what you want what we've got to
understand is the first ten years of it
is abyss rain are one of the most settle
periods in 16th century English history
she produces a religious sentiment which
is a nice middle road which almost
everybody can go along with and people
don't get to cross and even the Catholic
Bishops who burned and persecuted in his
abyss closest friends of God Father
Thomas Cranmer they're not touched
they're the most they have a very very
light house imprisonment you know or
they sort of stay with the Archbishop of
Canterbury's country cottages and one of
them there's a lovely letter actually
written to burn is sort of saying today
do you mind awfully if I have a week's
leave to go and see my mother was there
in London of Boerne rise back dear boy
of course with a future you've just got
and then Mary Queen of Scots comes to
England and the whole thing blows up
because the Catholicism now reap a
little sizes and from this point on was
Walsingham becomes necessary because you
go into a kind of cold war situation and
Walsingham manages the english cold war
but he wasn't gay he wasn't in the
Hammerman if you think of the film he
wasn't in the habit of murdering
pageboys after you after he buggered
them you know all that is complete
fiction
all that is designed to make the film
you know sexy stuff for today it's
rubbish yes it would I'm curious about
her relationship with him and and it
just as a postscript
did he die of syphilis oh gosh I
delighted all the really serious
questions are coming out here I did
Henry the eighth's have syphilis did the
children have congenital syphilis shall
we deal with the sexy bit first right I
hate to disappoint you Henry the
eighth's
did not have syphilis the reason I can
be so confident about this I was been
teasing you to ask questions about
evidence you haven't yet but we have
Henry the eighth's pharmaceutical record
for the last six months of his life
that's to say we have his drug bills we
know exactly what he's given and he is
not given mercury and the standard
treatment for syphilis at that point
amongst up-to-date doctors is mercury
and there's a much more the symptoms of
his I'll say he has none of the others
he has no other symptoms of syphilis and
at the front there's a French King did
have syphilis Francis the first did his
nose fell off I mean he had real
tertiary syphilis with the four horrors
of the thing and Henry the eighth's
ulcer doctors tell me is what's called a
let me get let me let me let me get this
right it's an osteoma lytic ulcer what
it sort of is it's a result of bone
splinter a shin splinter probably calls
in a jousting or riding injury that is
not removed and embeds itself in the
calf muscle and you get a cycle of
ulceration and you finally die a
septicemia neither Elizabeth nor Edward
nor Mary show any signs of syphilis
Edward dies probably of tuberculosis now
let's go back quickly to the relation
your your-your-your as it were one a
question I shouldn't believe let you get
away with two questions having refused
the gentleman at the end and but never
mind the your one a question on relation
between Edward and Elizabeth is close
they're of an age they're brought up
together
Edward joins their household they share
many of the same tutors they show a
similar extra
or miss Polly lingual skill you know
Elizabeth is fluent in about half a
dozen languages in Latin French Italian
Spanish Greek English but attitude to
puts it rather stiffly she only spoke
ancient Greek moderately well he's a
lovely live that but anyway and however
the closeness between the two of them
does not save Edward from excluding her
from the throne along with Mary at the
end of the raid it's his own personal
decision and he he like Mary herself
lets religion takes precedence over
everything else
and he comes to the conclusion that
Elizabeth cannot be trusted
to continue the sort of extreme
Protestantism that he wants and instead
he and he's also very very hostile to
the whole business of female succession
to the throne her childhood caretakers
introduced through Walter Raleigh and
Sir Humphrey Gilbert to her court and it
was through her I just passed your
occasion anyway I can't I can't answer
that question but I don't know it's the
short answer I don't know I mean
certainly they exercise very powerfully
and people like Kate actually exercise a
very powerful influence but it wanes
very quickly after she becomes Queen and
I the the people who matter are people
like Cecil they're the ones who really
go forward but but Kate actually makes a
terrible mistake
of backing the candidature of the king
of Sweden for Elizabeth's hand and
Elizabeth doesn't find him attractive
and it ruins her influence Elizabeth is
very tough about these kind of things
I'm somewhat on sorry on the specific I
can't answer can we have just one more
question I think is it would that be
sensible and yeah I was asking my guide
and mentor and just looking at the time
in so it's a boy have we time for a
little bit more one more question right
yes the gentleman at the back that
oh god that's incest too isn't it no no
no I die no absolutely not
shall we have a question Elizabeth yes
the influence of Elizabeth on the
ordinary relationships between men and
women very interesting question
Elizabeth is not a feminist icon she may
be now she has no view whatever or
rather she's deeply hostile to any other
woman exercising public office
yeah many women in power seem to be like
that and of course and she what what she
does she exercises as indeed Margaret
Thatcher is a very precise example of
this and she exercises power by an
extreme use of femininity by an
exaggeration of femininity you know
Margaret Thatcher if they like little
girl you know before she actually a sort
of you know slice the man's goodies off
I mean it was it was it was you you
remember you did do you remember me
Terrance phrase but Margaret Thatcher
the eyes of Caligula and the mouth of
Marilyn Monroe there's a there's a
different version of the same phrase
which is actually used on use on Queen
Elizabeth and I can never remember
whether it's Lord bird whether it's
whether it's Robert Cecil or whether
it's Francis Bacon and that she was in
truth more than a man and sometimes less
than a woman and I think that gets the
balance right but there's no revolution
in relations at all Elizabeth is
positively hostile positively hostile
was supposed to stop now aren't we
we do you think we've really had better
stop there seems to be lots of
enthusiasm
yes but we ought to leave tats that's
time for little book signing shouldn't
we yes right and we'll have a final
question yet in military affair oh it
isn't worth had no background in
military affairs she is at her weakest
on that I mean and this is also the area
you see you you ask your question on
women this is the area that Elizabeth
feels most worried about because when
she raises an army who has to command it
a man and he's got to be given enormous
amounts of money and practically an
open-ended brief and she hates that it's
one of the reasons she's so worried
about war is something she can't do
everything else she can control I think
that's a jolly good note on which to end
thank you all very much indeed